welcome back everybody we have Daniel
Radcliffe and Jane Krakowski on the line
they are both I'm actually in the new
unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt
Kimmy versus the Reverend now on Netflix
come check it out because the new Kimmy
Schmidt episode is about making choices
and because Twitter forces tough
questions upon us every day
Daniel Jane and I are going to deal with
some of those very tough choices and a
little segment called Kelly's Korn
Twitter questionnaire none of the most
liked and retweeted questions on Twitter
in the last month then we will all get
to answer so our first Twitter question
is from at the year of Elin your
quarantine nickname is how you feel
right now plus the last thing you ate
out of the cupboard
okay Jane you go ladies first go ahead
oh okay
mine would be hopeful nothing's my guess
would be like contented honey roasted
almonds it's quite long overwhelmed red
velvet cake but you know I usually do
feel overwhelmed when you eat too much
of it adds a friend to I obviously have
it all right so next question next to
the question is from at gif Mario who is
your racer of choice and Mario Kart on
Nintendo 64 Daniel what's yours
you're the game uh I was never very good
at it but I think the character that I
always liked playing as the most was
goofy I love you seems like cute and fun
yeah I know she's cool that would have
been mine no she's mine
what's yours Jane have you ever played
Mario Kart he's never played it
I somehow did not get into the video
game thing at all and I know with kids
their kid pressure my son hasn't really
gotten into Mia either I'm sort of like
trying to so I'll take you oh she -
she's awesome
Yoshi's it's a fun one okay though this
next one was supposed to buy at moving
sideways you are quarantined with the
first artist you saw in concert who is
it Dania we'll let you go first
well the first band I went to see was
the strokes which is quite cool
but I might be actual like real answer
which is that a concert I was taken to
or hosts like 10 would be better voice
so be me and the petal voice pretty cool
yeah okay you're cool whatever stream
tastes a little more Jersey where I was
raised
[Laughter]
your record team's gonna be a good
[Laughter]
honestly can't remember and this sounds
funny I can't remember it was either it
was this is gonna sound funny but it was
either the toadies which is my favorite
band of all time it's a Texas band their
alternative or it's Celine Dion so I
don't know which one but I think she'd
be a hell of a good time in the
quarantine cuz you've seen her on stage
but she is crazy funny but um okay
anyway next question is from at canted
cat sure is it bad if I order five
pounds of Mike and Ikes
no it's not bad I mean well five pounds
of it I mean expect to gain a good what
would your candy of choice be if you had
only one candy for this quarantine just
curious Oh
oh my goodness I know you actually don't
know my answer actually Daniel will know
this because they are my favorite and I
actually this is embarrassing their
Maynard's wine gums oh wow I love
Hawaiian gums what does that mean what
is that
to explain British we have a great
British store right near at me that
imports stuff from from Britain they
love British candy for some reason yeah
so I would I would be Mainers wine gums
but that's so that's Dan like that one
comes like incredibly chewy but all
like somehow very hard they like somehow
they they somehow managed to be both
chewy and hard to chew a milk dud it's
[Music]
gummy bears now I just thought of mine
chocolate-covered gummy bears I don't
even like regular gummy bears I just
like to chocolate-covered gummy bears
under that's weird
anyway amazing and you're welcome and
I'm sorry what would yours be Daniel any
kind of like tiny mozz bah like Snickers
just want some of those that like don't
feel like a Photoshop to bother you can
just sort of hammer away for hours yeah
no I don't know what that's like
all right well this last question is
from at Jilly Hendricks
has anyone else moved on from Waring's
from wearing sweatpants and is now just
wearing blankets what person is walking
around their house naked right now
that's awesome
I guess I'm sorry I didn't quite have
the guts to I was like I won't feel I
feel weird not having shoes on what I do
in interviews so it's full-on like mouth
it's still kind of snowy here in Montana
and some places on our ranch so I have
full-on snow boots and workout pants on
that I'm totally not going to work out
in theory I've had like a long time
theory that you shouldn't wear sweat
pants you should wear clothes that hurt
a little bit just to maintain your
weight my only weight maintaining advice
not diet and exercise just weird herzl
so you remember not to and it has gone
to the wind like I don't even want to
know how much weight I've gained during
Florentine because I'm wearing Stetson
everyday I know when you are elastic
everyday you just don't know you didn't
forget
okay well thank you so much everyone be
sure to use your time at home wisely and
watch unbreakable kimmy schmitt Kimi
versus the red moon on Netflix May 12th
it's gonna be awesome
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going